last week I was thinking of a girl I
never met and whose name I never knew I
thought of her walking off the ferry
coming from New Jersey and walking off
into New York from New Jersey she was
wearing a white dress and carrying a
parasol
the year was 1896 so I never saw her
myself a friend of Charles Foster Kane
by the name of Bernstein spoke about
this girl he only saw her once but he
spoke about her eloquently enough that I
sometimes think of her like he did for
the rest of her life and I haven't even
seen Citizen Kane in 20-plus years so
I'm remembering the memories of a man
that never existed played by another man
long gone in a scene written and
directed and photographed by others also
long gone this happens doesn't it we
incorporate stories into our lives into
our bodies whether it's the story of a
universe started inexplicably by a vast
and silent explosion or the story of a
woman pilot lost forever over the
Pacific or a majestic ship sinking in
the night on its maiden voyage or of
hundreds of thousands of men working for
centuries to build in the mud to build a
wall in Asia all these stories join
others in our heads and in our hearts
don't we talk about Fredo Corleone a
with as much authority and conviction
and affection as we do about a beloved
high school teacher what Kunta Kinte
wasn't real but Confucius was Pancho
Villa is more real than Madame Bovary
yeah whatever
some say Homer didn't exist but when I
see a bust of him made by an artist
seven centuries later why do I walk away
convinced that I know what Homer looked
like when he sat there surrounded by
listeners and aging blind man tell
telling his immortal tales well she was
in elementary school my daughter Ynez
heard of the controversy around the
identity of William Shakespeare was he
actually this or that fellow was he
Christopher Marlowe or did he just have
a drink with a pot in a pub with
Christopher Marlowe ones or was that in
a movie after some back-and-forth
subject my daughter said to me dad I
know who Shakespeare was I said really
who she said he was the man who wrote
those plays mystery solved all we need
to know about him is the stories he told
and how they move us beyond that he was
a man like any other man only more so
this same daughter by the way once
summoned me to her room at bedtime and
asked point-blank dad Adam and Eve true
or false that was not long after her
sister Isabel cried in desperation dad
Jesus was Jewish proving that sometimes
stories overlap in ways that are
contradictory but enriching one of my
favorite movies when I was a kid was the
1959 Ben Hur I eventually saw an earlier
version from 1925 the silence scratched
bleached black-and-white images
convinced me for a moment that it was
actual footage of a chariot race from
the Roman Empire it all looks so remote
so genuine it was only a few moments
later not without disappointment that I
returned to my ruthless senses and
accepted that the plebeians and the
bleachers were extras from the San
Fernando Valley their clothing
manufactured in Culver City their
sandals in Reseda their Latin a little
bit more than rusty every year when I
ride for this evening I think of a
charismatic general who was a character
in a screenplay that won the nickel the
night that Anton was here I don't
remember the name of that very fine
script but remember that general it
still makes me a little sad that he died
at the end of that story I'd rather
think he might have retired to Sardinia
instead the sheer pain in the ass of
writing a story his only overcome by the
sheer delight of telling it there really
is nothing more fun than you can do with
your clothes on then hearing a story
well told when a good story touches you
it becomes indestructible
and so storytellers themselves are
indestructible congratulation to you
guys and gals our winners tonight
you have contributed to an endlessly
flowing tradition the most human and
humane of all that started a hundred
thousand years ago around a small
campfire retelling the killing of an
animal the sound of distant thunder the
color of a cloud speculating about the
stars above
the motivations of the moon the thoughts
of a hawk since the very beginning we
have counted on stories to help us
digest what we cannot comprehend how
come the Sun never skips a day why do
things not fall upwards why am I unable
to anticipate my wife's feelings nothing
well told can never vanish if it was
seen and heard and felt it would be
alive for as long as humans walk the
earth when Emily was having sex in that
movie hundreds of other Parisians were
all when having sex remember tell me
that didn't happen I mean it's Paris for
crying out loud it's all alive and well
Tootsie brushing her Tootsie brushing
her wig Harold Lloyd hanging from a
clock Gina Lollobrigida painting the
town a baby and a carriage rolling down
the steps of Odessa and town at warp
speed and town fighting vampires and
town in love with an English girl
they're all here people forever and ever
to make us cry and to make us laugh
thank you